today we're going to talk about how law
school is just like the LSAT and also
how it is completely different
Lillian reached out to me and said hello
I came across your page and I'm so glad
I did I'm currently preparing to take
the LSAT in September I will hopefully
attend law school next fall I was
wondering if you have any tips on LSAT
preparation when I wrote my response to
Lily and actually got me thinking about
how preparing for the LSAT was actually
kind of similar to the way that I
prepared for my law school finals so
here is a condensed version of my
response to Lillian first tip number one
take a well-known prep course it's of
course a lot of money but it's money
well spent because the LSAT is a test
unlike any other test you'll ever take
it involves reading comprehension logic
games and it's very unusual but what you
find is that as you become more familiar
with the LSAT you learn the strategies
that help you learn how to take logic
games you learn how to comprehend the
reading sections that are provided it
just takes time and it takes a lot of
practice believe it or not law school is
actually very similar law school exams
are unlike anything in undergrad a law
school essay is nothing like a college
exam or a college essay but the more you
familiarize yourself with law school
essays the better you can become at them
just like there are strategies for the
LSAT there are strategies that you can
learn to take an issue spotting exam and
a sit every time it just takes time and
it takes practice and that brings me to
the second point that I told Lillian
take lots of practice exams before I
took the LSAT I took every single
publicly available LSAT that I could get
my hands on the summer before my LSAT I
studied every day probably from 9:00 to
5:00 on weekdays and probably from 9:00
to 6:00 on weekends I considered it my
job to take as many practice tests as
possible because as I said before I
could see that taking the LSAT was a
skill and like any skill you get better
at it the more you
practiced and it's the same with law
school get your hands on as many
practice exams as you can it's okay if
you're taking exams from professors that
are not at your school it's okay if
they're ten years old
in law school the law that's taught in
your first year doesn't really change
that much and as a result you can take
tests from 20 years ago you can take
tests from other schools and other
professors get your hands on as many as
you can and take as many practice tests
as you can as early as you can if you do
that you will get better at law school
exams and you are much more likely to
get AIDS when it comes to the actual
test in your class and that brought me
to the third thing that I told billion
take practice exams under non ideal
circumstances on test day you're going
to be stressed you're going to be tired
you're going to be distracted when
Lillian takes the LSAT it's not going to
be on her schedule it's going to be on
their schedule it's far too easy to take
practice exams on your schedule after
you've had coffee after you've had a
good night's sleep when there's no
pressure once you've established a
baseline competence take practice tests
with the music on with other
distractions immediately upon waking up
we're at 3 o'clock in the morning and
always take practice exams under
real-time pressure because I guarantee
when you walk into your first law school
final exam you're going to be freaked
out it's a natural reaction but if you
can practice under non ideal
circumstances then you're going to be
way ahead of all of those other people
who are taking the same exam and who are
even more freaked out than you are when
I responded to Lillian I realized that
taking the LSAT and taking a law school
final exam and the way that you prepare
for them are actually pretty similar
unfortunately there is little to no
carryover between the strategies that go
into the LSAT and the strategies that go
into a law school final exam issue
spotting exams are just two different
but the underlying methodology is the
same so when you get to law school don't
throw the baby out with the bathwater
use your good habits that you learned
when you practice the LSAT and bring
that into law school and you'll be way
ahead of everybody else
oh and one last thing if you're getting
ready for law school check this out we
put together a free ebook called the
ultimate pre-law checklist just click
the link below to download if some of
our best tips and strategies for getting
ahead before you start law school and it
will put you miles ahead of your
classmates just click below and also if
you like this video please subscribe to
our Channel we come out with new videos
on how to crush law school all the time
so thanks a lot thanks for stopping by
[Music]
[Music]